the Demonic nun known as valik is a
fallen angel who was summoned through a
rift in Romania during the Dark Ages
recognizing the threat Catholic Knights
sealed valak beneath Saint kartha's
Monastery with the blood of Christ
keeping the demon at Bay for hundreds of
years but all that changed during World
War II when the Abbey was bombed and the
seal was broken Alec kills all the nuns
in the Abbey and eventually sets its
sights on Sister Irene though we don't
know what will happen in the nun too we
know that the titular demon survives
through Frenchy using him to inflict
Lorraine Warren with a vision of her
husband Ed's death from there valak is a
catalyst for the events of the first
Conjuring in The Conjuring 2 where it
reveals itself physically once again
taking the form of the trademark none a
demon with a similar name spelled with a
c instead of a k is described in a
number of grimoires including the Lesser
key of Solomon with the power to control
all sorts of serpents valak is known as
a president of demons with somewhere
between 30 to 38 Legions under his
control